هنا تل ابيب حيث صافرات الاندار واصوات
الانفجارات التي بدات تدوي منذ ساعات
الصباح الاولى في عمليه وصفت بالمباحث
لدوله الاحتلال واعادت الى الاذهان ذكريات
حرب السادس من اكتوبر عام
1973 فما الذي يحدث في
اسرائيل
بعد ان اغلق الاحتلال معبر ايريز المنفذ
الوحيد لسكان غزه في سبتمبر ايلول الماضي
وردا على الانتهاكات المستمره للمسجد
الاقصى والاعتداء على المصلين العزل
والاقتحامات المتكرره لمدن الضفه الغربيه
اعلنت حركه المقاومه عن بدء عمليه طوفان
الاقصى رغبه منها بحسب ما ذكرت في وضع حد
للجرائم التي ترتكب بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني العمليه بدات اطلاق اكثر من
5000 صاروخ وقذيفة
شاعر هاني جيف الذي يمتد على مساحه 180 كت
الضربات وصلت الى اسدود شمالا وبئر السبع
شرقا المثير للانتباه انه وفي حادثه غير
مسبوقه تجاوز مقاتلون فلسطينيون السياج
الفاصل بين غزه ومناطق
48 تحديدا في المنطقه الشماليه والشماليه
الشرقيه مثل زيكيم وسديت وناح العوز وناتي
فوت كيسوفيم الصواريخ لم تتوقف عند حدود
الغلاف بل امتدت الى ما هو ابعد حتى وصلت
الى تل ابيب على بعد 80 كيلومترا وهو ما
ادى الى حاله من الهلع والرعب في مطار بن
جوريون وسط دوي اجهزه
[موسيقى]
الانذار